Speaker 1: OK, let's talk about infrastructure
spending and green energy and other things
that Joe Biden wants to do. Joe Biden is actually
trying to do some interesting things when it comes
to infrastructure and climate, which includes
kind of reorienting some industries to be more
sustainable over the long term to create jobs
in the area of green rather than dirty energy.
And the climate denying right wing is absolutely
furious with Joe Biden for wanting to do this,
even though he ran on it. He's just doing the
things he ran on doing. And they are having
a field day over the last few days focusing
on completely bogus claims that Joe Biden's
climate and infrastructure plan for America
would ban steak and beer. Now, what is really
important to understand about this is that
lots of the people that are saying this stuff.
They stopped short of saying Biden has
proposed this, but they sometimes will say
Biden's proposals would lead to this type
of thing or what Biden actually wants is.
But then some of them don't get the message
that that's the language you're supposed to
use. And they straight up say this is in Biden's
proposals. And of course, it's not. So let's go
to the beginning and figure out how this
all came to be the banning stake thing,
the kernel of the for lack of a better term,
the kernel of the banning stake goes back to
2020. When Donald Trump said that in Aoki's JND
in Alexandria, Cacio, Cortez's Green New Deal,
Kowsar Band, OK, there was not actually any
mention of cows in the Green New Deal framework
back then. There was a supporting document
later released by AOK staff which said,
We aren't sure we'll be able to fully
get rid of farting cows and airplanes.
Now, that wasn't suggesting let's try to get rid
of cows and airplanes. It was merely stating we're
never going to get rid of cows and airplanes and
therefore we should have other ways to work within
that reality to deal with the things that impact
the environment. So there was never any banning,
of course, that became AOC will ban cows. And
if Biden does the green New Deal, he will also
ban cows. Now, Biden doesn't support the green
New Deal. He took some elements from the Green New
Deal in and integrated it into his green energy
proposal. So we're already like three layers
removed. None of this is true. But this weekend,
because the Green New Deal was reintroduced,
not by Joe Biden, they are going nuts. And the the
latest trajectory of this is that the Daily Mail
ran a really weird piece connecting Biden's
climate plan to some study from Michigan about
meat that has nothing to do with Biden.
And Republicans ran with it. Trumpy and
Congresswoman Lauren Bobert tweeted, Joe Biden's
climate plan includes cutting 90 percent of red
meat from Dietze by 2030 and limits us to four
pounds per year. Fox News ran with it, saying
Biden's climate requirements cut 90 percent
of red meat from diet, max four pounds per
year. Don Junior read tweets saying, I'm pretty
sure I ate four pounds of red meat yesterday.
That's going to be a hard no for me. But the
University of Michigan study that they are citing
has nothing to do with Joe Biden's plan at all.
It just looks at what would happen to emissions
if people did certain things. And it points out
if people cut red meat consumption by 90 percent,
then emissions would go down. And The Daily Mail
took the hypothetical percentage reduction and
somehow linked it to Joe Biden's plan. And this is
what it leads to. They just don't care. They spent
the weekend talking about it. It's completely
made up. And then Donald Trump's former economic
adviser, Larry Kudlow, he unintentionally cell
phone himself. He went on Fox Business and said
under Joe Biden, we would have to be drinking
plant based beer on the Fourth of July. This is
my new favorite thing. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: So get ready. You can throw
back a plant based beer with your grilled
brussel sprouts and wave your American flag.
Call it July 4th green.
Speaker 1: Now, why is that
funny? If you know anything about beer, you
would know beer is already a plant based,
plant based beer or as I call it, beer. Beer is
made from water, malt, hops and yeast. Water, we
know is not an animal product. Malt is germinated.
Cereal, grain, that's a plant. That's a plant
hops are the flowers of the Hopp plant,
Hummel's Lupita's, that's another plant.
Yeasts are eukaryotic single celled microorganisms
classified as fungus. That's almost more of
a mushroom than a plant, but it's not meat. But
this stuff just gets repeated uncritically. Biden
will make us drink plant based beer as if it's
some kind of weird thing. If it were even true,
which of course it isn't, because it can't be
true because beer is plant based to begin with.
Next thing you know, we'll have plant based
corn, plant based eggplant might be on the menu
plant based. What's interesting about this is
that plant based is now a fear inducing buzzword,
even things that are plant based by their nature.
They will stick the word plant based on
it, and it's supposed to give you a certain
image, a certain understanding, it's actually
sort of like, you know, sometimes you'll see
the gluten free label on, like almonds and you
would think there's yourself where gluten free. It
is just an ailment. It's not it's not gluten, but
it has a certain message because the gluten free
has become trendy and people see gluten free on
an album. They say here's a great it's a marketing
thing, even though lots of things are just it's
just it's just an ingredient. Much of the same
way that the word socialism is used to describe
the government doing anything by right wingers.
Plant based is now a buzzword among the right
with a very particular connotation, and they use
it even to describe things that are naturally
plant based. Now, here's a strategy question.
Do we ignore or challenge this stuff head on?
If you ignore it, it runs the risk of exactly
what happened this weekend that they go crazy
with. Biden will ban red meat and beer on right
wing media and then it starts to infect the social
media networks and you start seeing legacy media
reporting on it in a way that's not as critical of
the insanity as it should be. It starts to spread
uncontrolled if you ignore it at the same time
you address it and you know you're spending time
on it rather than something else. I actually
don't know the answer. I'd be curious to hear
from you. Maybe we'll even set up a poll about
this on The David Pakman Show Instagram page.
You should be following us there. Find us on
Instagram at David Pakman show. You can find me on
Instagram at David Pakman. And we'll be back right
after this dystopian new polling data from CBS.